what's the deal with airplane peanuts
the kill Tony New Year's Eve 2-day arena
show not only featured a Mr Beast 10K
giveaway Adam Ray dresses Dr Phil
meeting Dr Phil a David Lucas Hall of
Fame ceremony jelly roll singing the
National Anthem and referee sugar Shan
Ali but also was the setting for Hans
Kim vers Rick Diaz a battle for regular
ship that has stirred up more drama than
ever before in the 10year history of
kill Tony and in this video we're going
to recap every single thing that
happened from the beginning of night one
till the end of Night 2 with help from a
few special guests that were backstage
to witness the chaos of this 48 hours in
Austin Texas also this video will
contain spoilers and we're in a new
studio so that's cool before we get into
Hans vers Rick let's take a look at the
surprise panel members that Tony brought
out for these special events starting
off with Adam Ray night one which some
people were calling the highlight of the
entire night the Relentless energy of
his Dr Phil character carried the show
through some rough bucket poles and at
the end of the episode they surprised
Adam Ray with a video from the real Dr
Phil who delivered the message that Adam
had been named the 2023 kill Tony guest
of the Year Adam Ray dressed as Dr Phil
is strangely becoming one of the
funniest bits in comedy podcasting so
let me know in the comments if you'd
like a compilation of those best moments
soon as many people expected the night
two New Year's Eve guest panel were the
dogs Matt mccusker and Shane Gillis who
according to Tony hinchcliff are the
most requested guests in the history of
the show and although their presence is
naturally electric the quality of the
bucket poles did not give them much to
work with as panel members they were
however involved in one of the most
intense moments from either night when
both Matt and Shane had to cast their
vote for who they thought won between
Rick Diaz and Hans Kim now before we get
into what happened with the regulars one
of the biggest takeaways from this show
in hindsight was the bucket pole system
for these big arena shows most people
agree one of the best parts about kill
Tony is the fact that literally anybody
can sign up for a chance to be on stage
from legit homeless people to
professional Comics you never know what
strange creature will appear next and
that's definitely part of the fun but
when it comes to back-to-back shows and
soldout Arenas with thousands of people
paying money to stream it online it felt
almost awkward to have a majority of the
bucket poles be random fans of the show
who are out of breath from running to
the stage from the nose beds and who
have also never done standup in their
life and don't even want to become
comedians again this is part of what
makes a show great but it is weird to
have a section full of Serious Comics
who are hungry for this insane
opportunity sit by and watch people with
nothing to say go up and get booed by
8,000 people in real life these were the
type of bucket poles that Tony would
kick off stage 2 seconds into the
interview but it almost seemed like he
was a bit nicer this time trying his
best to forge ahead for some good
interview content or perhaps fill time
while the next person made their journey
to Backstage in the grand scheme of
things HB is still a small Arena so when
kill Tony takes their talons to Masson
Square Garden in August it'll be curious
to see if they make any adjustments to
the bucket poles although I'm not even
sure what those adjustments would be as
we all know the main event was Hans Kim
versus Rick Diaz if you're not aware of
the fierce history between these two
that led us to this exact moment we have
multiple videos breaking down every
single detail of their beef including
two interviews with Rick that you can
watch right after this the battle was
intense as sugar Shan Ali was introduced
as the official referee for this event
Rick Diaz went first with a very tight
and calculated 1 minute and 17sec set of
his unique quick hitting style up next
was Hans Kim who also Came Out Swinging
with a 1 minute and 16-second set that
had a lot of strong moments and featured
more of a personal touch something that
got brought up on stage that has been
discussed a lot by fans recently is the
lpms or laughs per minute of each set
because comedy is technically subjective
the use of LPM seems like a tangible way
to measure who had the better
performance but once you realize the
vast amounts of varying comedic Styles
this statistic loses a bit of meaning
for example some guys like Dave
Chappelle Ron White or nor McDonald
might tell long jokes that only have one
laugh every 5 minutes vers other styles
like Mark Norman Sam Morel or Mitch
Hedberg who will hit you with multiple
punches in a short period of time all
these guys are hilarious but use
different tools to make their audiences
laugh so using LPM to determine the
better comic is definitely not an exact
science Shane Gillis and Matt mccusker
both gave the nod to Rick Diaz but as
any kill Tony fan knows too well all the
biggest competitions on this show are
settled by audience Applause which is
also not an exact science but if you
really listen to the name get announced
HB Arena reached a slightly higher
octave for Hans Kim giving Hans the full
Standing Ovation whereas Rick got around
half this match up played out perfectly
for Tony Hinchcliffe Who as a big fan of
pro wrestling has been adding new twists
to his show for the past few years
trying to constantly raise the stakes of
each and every performance seeing things
get actually heated between Hans and
Rick on stage only added to the lore of
this battle but it would have been nice
to hear Rick's actual responses to Hans
instead of Hans cutting him off every
time Rick tried to speak this was
definitely a result of the real anger
Hans was feeling at the time which is
understandable given this random guy is
trying to take the best gig in the world
from you and is actually funny enough to
be a threat but like Rick said on stage
he won either way the massive amount of
exposure he's garnered from taking full
advantage of his time on this show is
honestly genius and ever since this
matchup took place last weekend the
debate online has only grown there are
plenty of fans on both sides but some of
the neutral parties have been quick to
point out it seems like Tony was never
going to let Hans lose now only because
of what he's meant to the show over the
past few years but also because it makes
no logistical sense to add a new regular
who lives in Brussels here to discuss
all of this more in- depth from her
eyewitness point of view is Austin
comedian and Kil Tony record holder for
longest onstage interview Karen Jones
Karen thank you so much for joining the
show today you were in attendance for
both night one and night two of kill
Tony in HB Arena please tell us a little
bit about what this experience was like
from your point of view well uh it was
really a relief that the um The
Comedians got to watch the show this
time normal kill Tony filming we are we
are uh secluded in a bar next door so
this was great we were actually in the
seating but from a little bit back
behind the stage and so we could see the
audience we could see the show
participants we could hear things it
made for even a more festive Carnival
atmosphere Among The Comedians or
regulars who sign up well the main event
was obviously Hans Kim vers Rick Diaz a
battle that Hans Kim ultimately was
named the winner of in the end please
tell us from your point of view what was
it like in the actual Arena the moment
that the winner was announced when they
announced the winner of the Hans Kim
Rick Diaz Showdown it was pretty clear
that uh Hans Kim won the audience
approval sitting back with the other
comedians that was not the case The
Comedians strongly favored Rick Diaz and
some reacted with anger maybe especially
because both Shane and Matt before the
vote was taken both commented that they
thought that Rick had the stronger set
we had sha Ali acting as referee there
was a lot of hope that Rick was going to
beat uh Hans Kim personally I'm a Hans
Kim gal I like his humor but I was one
of the few people that was cheering for
Hans in the comedian section we saw a
lot of first timers get p on stage or
people that don't even do stand up at
all just on stage with really nothing to
say as a real comedian backstage in the
loading tank with all the other legit
Comics what was that Vibe like when
these rookies kept getting called on
stage my perception of the first night
was that that first bucket pool uh was
what most of the disappointment the ey
the criticism that she took up time that
one of us could have got and the show
was great except for the bucket poles no
nobody was any good it was comical
because Mr Beast showed up at the end
with a briefcase with $110,000 to award
to the best bucket pool and they were
all equally bad a young kid who was like
18 or 20 years old went into some joke
when he got pulled about what a stud his
dad was and all his siblings and anyway
the joke was going nowhere the audience
was booing and so out of what appeared
to be defensiveness this young man said
my my dad has so much sex that he broke
his penis that guy came on stage and uh
the comedians Shane Matt Tony everybody
said well you know if this really
happened we want to see the evidence and
the guy didn't want to pull out his
penis in a an arena so uh Tony said just
pull it out and show the people at the
table now of course all of his comedians
were sitting behind the table so he was
pulling it out in front of the table and
all the comedians in the back so there
were a couple more crappy bucket pools
Mr Beast come came out and once again by
Applause uh it was determined that uh
they called him split dick dad split
dick dad won the 10,000 bucks for Mr
Beast and the show was funny there were
regulars that came there there David
Lucas man davidc was really something
there was a montage of him from the
beginning to the end and he cried and
he's such a you know a a crap talking
roasting guy to see him be completely
humble and um the gratitude that he
showed was touching and and the audience
like that the comedians like you know
the comedians weren't out for blood and
booing the whole time when something
really remarkable and sweet happened
like that
uh I think most of my peers were truly
Touched By by the performance of David
Lucas well Karen thank you so much for
your time today thank you for joining
the show and if you have not seen the
kill Tony Arena shows yet according to
Tony Hinchcliffe both night one and
night two will be uploaded to YouTube in
about 5 weeks but if you don't want to
wait that long the replay tickets are
still available for purchase online
guest spots from last week The Joe Rogan
Experience had on John Reeves and Tony
hinchcliff two bears one cave was Burt
and Tom Tom and Bert Gary Goldman was on
bertcast kill Pony this week was the
regulars cam Hans and William ymh are
you garbage and we might be drunk did
not have guests Matt and Shane secret
podcast had Shane's new roommate lame
Lee on the show taste buds battled
giving versus receiving gifts Ian fance
was a guest on Whiskey Ginger hey babe
said goodbye to their beloved producer
homeless pimp bad friends were joined by
Adam Ray AKA Dr Phil and episode one of
the way back with Ryan sichler featured
Tom sagora we would shoot fireworks off
in house like we were terrible kids now
my kids also like they when they when I
found Ellis painting the walls with his
hands I [__] lost my mind the [__]
pain all over the what are you doing
just going crazy he what do they do he
goes I don't like when you yell at me
when you raise your voice I'm just a kid
he says that yeah he goes if you just
talk to me in a normal voice I'm like
dude and I just start laughing cuz he's
being like he's right and he's being
like rational I'm like why are you
painting the walls he goes sometimes my
brain man my brain man
just tells me to do St I was
like okay I love it dude this past
weekend with Theo vanon welcomed UFC
middleweight champion Sean Strickland H
Foley was on the Honeydew first date
featured Nikki Howard the blocks podcast
had on Lil re tiger belly had on Joel
mccale being in with Jordan welcome
Francis Ellis and JP McDade Giannis
papus visited stav's World stav Ros was
on Soder Trevor Wallace took a ride down
the Harland Highway and on toas show
Daniel head on hallmar Christmas movie
star Luke McFarlin as far as new standup
specials are either out right now or
coming out soon Paul Aliyah's debut
special Detroit Player is available
right now on mint comedy.com feel free
to use the promo code Paul to not only
watch the special but also access tons
of exclusive content other specials out
right now include Ricky deras armagedon
and Dave Chappelle the dreamer both out
on Netflix Sam Talent the Toads moral is
on the Matt and Shane YouTube page also
out on YouTube is Josh Wolf here for the
fun Shane Torres the blue-eyed Mexican
and Carmen Lynch queif week and a few
hours are in the works right now that
will be com out soon January 9th Pete
Davidson turbo ferelli comes out on
Netflix followed by Dusty slay's debut
Netflix special Working Man on January
23rd and one last big announcement to
end this episode voting for The Joke
World Awards is currently underway if
you haven't heard about this yet
basically we set up some voting for
categories like comedian of the Year
podcast of the Year podcast guest of the
Year newcomer of the Year special of the
Year YouTube special of the year and
more anyone can go vote right now if you
use the link in the description of this
video go throw in your two cents and be
sure to turn on post notifications to
this channel so you don't miss our video
next week announcing the winners also be
sure to check out the best moments of
December on the end screen right after
this thank you for
watching joke
World it J
world and the world is
wld that's a great uh YouTube channel
joke World check it out